Borja Nazir used to feel safe in his
home but now he's finding it
increasingly difficult to fight off dark
thoughts I'm scared and I get nightmares
of the incident I see soldiers
approaching as if they're going to shoot
me again I'm not able to sleep properly
I keep on waking up a few times during
the night my mind stops working
sometimes and I get palpitations last
month as protests swept through Srinagar
and indian-administered Kashmir Bor han
was shot by paramilitary officers
he's been recovering ever since where
Hans father Nazir holds up his sons
x-rays and says at least 350 shotgun
pellets were removed from where Hans
body yet as worried as he is about Bohr
Hans physical injuries Nazir's equally
concerned about his son's mental health
he has become violent and shouts that he
will jump from the window at night when
he is asleep he shouts
they are coming soldiers are coming then
we convince them that no one is here
everything is fine don't worry then I
keep him on my lap and try to make him
sleep health care professionals have
long known of the mental health problems
of people in Kashmir according to a
survey conducted by Doctors Without
Borders in 2015 45 percent of the adult
population in Kashmir showed symptoms of
significant mental distress a growing
number of doctors are now warning that
India's recent move revoking autonomy in
indian-administered Kashmir and it's
security lockdown are limiting people's
access to mental health care services in
the valley some predict this will also
cause a rise in the number of people
with mental health issues obviously
mentally this glandon has an impact on
this mental cycle of the patients as
well as the norm
individual because this landowner has
affected our all eaters of the life like
we can't move out of our houses as
normally just last year xia Aneesa began
her career as a lawyer
Xia used to feel enthusiastic about all
she hoped to accomplish in the future
that's all changed when I go out of my
home
I see shops shut down there's no vehicle
on the roads no no nothing nothing on
the roads of Kashmir when I come back
I'm confined to four walls of my house
of my home and I cannot think about my
future
now Xia is despondent what next what
next in my life how do I plan my life
how do I start my life my professional
life Radha so while all these slam downs
while I'm sitting at my place I get
suicidal thoughts at the same time I'm
suffering from anxiety with nowhere else
to go
Xia says she can only wait and worry in
this room whose walls used to provide
comfort but now feel like they are
closing in on her I'm a gym gym
aljazeera